Identify currency bill with Seeing AI
One of the things that Seeing AI can do is
recognize currency bills.
Currently, we only do US dollars.
This is important because US currency is all
the same size and even the same color.
So, it’s hard to differentiate.
What some people would do then is folded it
into different shapes or put it in different
parts of your wallet.
But to do that, you still need to go through
and identify each of the notes.
You can do this with our currency channel.
Simply place a phone over a note and hear
the denomination.
It’s lunchtime here, so let’s see how
much money I have here.
I’m just gonna put the phone over the bill.
 One US dollar
One dollar.
Unfortunately, that’s not gonna buy much
today.
Let’s see what else I have.
 20 US dollars
Cool!
20 dollars, that’s more like it.
You’ll see that this is quite a nice $20
bill.
What about if it was all scrumpled up.
Let me do that for you and let’s see it
looks a bit older now.
So, let’s see what is gonna say now.
 20 US dollars
Cool!
So just as fast.
it’s recognizing notes that are just not
as pristine.
That’s currency for you.
Let’s go and get some lunch!
Microsoft logo appears.